c'est bien un duel qui se joue derrière
ces portes défense contre défense lui
contre elle lui que ses proches
décrivent comme un garçon profondément
non violent un temps aux prises avec la
drogue elle oisive amoureuse possessive
voir envahissante
le couple vivait en vase clos et sont
donc tous les deux présents le jour du
drame le bruit les coûts le transport du
corps s'il homme s'accuse spontanément
du meurtre on comprend difficilement que
sa compagne n'ai rien vu ou plutôt
qu'elle n'ait rien voulu voir la
surprise aussi la stupeur le choc de se
retrouver dans une situation qu'elle n'a
absolument pas envisagé qui lui tombe
dessus et je pense que c'est à mon avis
l'agrégation de ces éléments
l'immaturité le sentiment amoureux
le choc qui peuvent expliquer une
passivité et et une réaction qui n'est
pas celle qu'on peut envisager mais le
doute plane
s'il a d'abord totalement dédouané sa
compagne qu'il pensait enceinte
le meurtrier présumé l'a ensuite
accabler son adn est présent dans la
voiture de la victime sur le scotch
enroulé autour du cadavre
au point qu'elle est un temps elle aussi
mise en examen pour meurtre un chef
d'accusation abandonné en cours
d'instruction
c'est un procès biaisé c'est une affaire
qui n'honore pas la justice et je
considère que d'avoir renvoyé
la compagne de mon client que du chef de
recel de cadavre et de modification de
scène de crime est incompréhensible
quand on voit ce dossier si on ne
dénonce pas cette situation
on est devant une injustice et une
erreur judiciaire qui s'annonce à grands
pas assis à bonne distance l'un de
l'autre dans le box et ancien amant
s'ignorent lui pleurs elle non lui il
risque trente ans l 3